now it's talking to somebody about that
with Phoenix he's got perfect for us
because he might have been over drought
and fire totally from the heavens and
very bluntly got the 200 good thought it
was - hi Scott that we saw the bounce
pass dog a while ago this thing a little
lob and lovely almost late getting up in
the air like he goes cats with the one
hand
puts it down as hard as he needs to for
the first time he's a trouble Taylor
Duncan
[Applause]
just a straight-up jump a good backdoor
he does the straight-up
Tipton and then you get grant on the
wing and if you don't stop him I mean
making shots get to the
chair regrets later this crash the
weakside no one ever blocks out a weak
side perfect timing as Jeremy grid got
the lead back
and this crowd excited
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Gary does a good job Easley stays with
him corset and see if that's what you
get
when an offensive player all these tall
butchers trying to do is get the foul
and a good job by Beasley just to stay
away from the foul and the Tories great
to come on the game lean in pizzas
trying to get contact night in
Sacramento with 77 70s going higher
tonight
the thrill third found the first six
plus minutes here look at that that's
reminiscent of Gary Harris last year
with the spinner and once again in you
you got Johnson on him he just moves
right past
pelicans up by three Harris got the step
puts a start a game up did please wake
me up
thank you my god
from the field how about last night of
the NBA 101 beautiful behind the back
pass up a hot foot bill Sapp job by
Plumlee on a truck not able to find the
shot cut but now five
I can switch everything and you need
some help defense I got you back and
become pity pet that out of their great
block right there rescues you and then
buried in the Geoghan with the two main
game the clock the clock two at rate at
two seconds he's shooting about a 17 and
a half 19 foot fadeaway jump shot
dirk nowitzki style
[Applause]
Bertie to your kids
[Applause]
Yogesh
[Applause]
Oh
remember the Nuggets have already used
their coaches challenge or they might be
able to replay that reluctant at times
Millsaps into Barton Millsaps nine to
shoot
Barton out to yogic yoke it's falling
away
[Applause]
Yogesh buries it he's telling official
he thought he got slept on the arm again
it's a two pointer rattling ho see it
lets you do a high-five they're saying
but doubles
[Applause]
so pretty he sees him reads Hitler once
again see how the weak side goes asleep
and you just get a cutter weak side goes
to sleep the smallest guy in the floor
he cuts the basket gets a layup
it gives that guard a chance to just
float in you let me stop them we're
partners down the lane
welcome home Willy
[Applause]
we got some pandemonium going on at
Pepsi Torrey Craig ignites the Nuggets
by portent need to see from him more
effectively well Ali I think you you
he's got to just impose himself on the
game but this is the other and that was
an incredible finish pot Gary hair has
taken that good defense and gotten out
and created easy opportunities in
transit
can't get yourself in a sense but that
was done intentionally is it inside
again it goes it off the backboard the
Red Sea parted brush yoga just done that
in the past mass of other players now
part pass it out divorce swing it
Jeremy grant
once Portis came out of balance Francis
went right by his or down the siding
he knows his face he pees it on beating
low health his gonna tell you what long
strides of Jeremy grant turned on Barton
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
one more time
48:20
[Applause]
so late he's waiting for a backhoe right
there he wanted Marie to go back door
looks at the clock he's only got a
couple of seconds so he let me let me
dirt this pick that foot up and what he
did it made the three Jeremy grant
coming in he throws it down whoa let's
just not even a roll just to go
blueberry slapped the arm so the
officials have been alerted that mumbly
is bleeding
[Applause]
[Applause]
this will be him pushing underneath same
official there's a little back to her
button and it was high up as I've ever
seen murder in that case there
Wow Jones although it was whirring
initiate contact
[Music]
that's by Nicola yoga did all the body
sitting there worried about genre the
ball that just no looks integrand
instead of standing out somewhere else
once you got Jackson watching Joker so
he just attacks the basket and not the
way by Murray and Murray's racing for
ago
I feel like he's trying to get the
fellows goal in here Scott
[Music]
gonna windmill it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Murray draws the foul wow what a finish
34 from Murray
throw it in he's going to the stuffs
good job on the Wizards cutting the
water off of Jamal Murray I would
probably say that's probably the first
to murder it's like that Murray's got
it's two-on-one let's run it
Elliot Park and close it down Beasley
and Murray you have to think this is
gotta hit yo kitchen Murray give him the
first touch off the inbound pass
finney-smith guarding the foul tips it
away 15 to go
yokas inside for the lead
got it efficient basketball go to your
best player again a mismatch and
punishing four seconds remaining in the
koi Leonard splits two guys but instead
of Duncan EC he lays it up
[Applause]
Martin's give it to your kids
[Applause]
[Music]
you just never know what's gonna happen
Jory Craig not only does he block and
Christie saves it at the yep which was
big then what's his past he just drops
it off to Tory a fat can they get a
little closer than JA coming in it's
blocked out of there Boris has it and he
scores him you seem to beat right there
but he never quits it actually starts
time in it and by Joker just being a
little present in double clutches the
Montaigne just keeping Hill on his side
I'm just looking to get on the forward
here Murray around the screen over to
Gary Harris Gary learn he didn't go up
easy here he went up to dunk it got
found should have been an ant one watch
across the face rate this season high
nineteen at Detroit 1977 as the Nuggets
what to get
5012
[Applause]
having tried to dunk it though and pull
Jamie was right there to say Jeremy
grant final three seconds Beasley's on
the drop rate there was on the arm and
then trades legs once again to boot yeah
in Tribune you're batting first right
there's there's a foul on the gather if
they called that one
then there might be a few seconds left
[Music]
the other candidate
watch this bit moving this side hangs on
lip there's one Smith let me go dr. J oh
off the glass
sweet that might there's the move that
meant right there that beats everybody
if you liked it you like that better
than married the that's the slinger not
from Serbia great pass and good patience
on Jeremy sixteen on the clock
[Applause]
shots made and tagged in the basket in
that one by Monta budget
Gary Harris
about eight times on that play if
anybody ever wins cylinder gets by 12
Vegas Murray's on the draw in the lane
lost it for a moment
five to shoot give it to Murray Murray's
got to pull the trigger baby away game
nikola sets the screen jamal murray
refuses that screen because he knows the
hornets have been looking to switch that
all game long nope it's a little crumble
in the lane but he gathers himself sends
it out to Jamal how about that a little
fade away for the blue arrow as
beautiful as it can be over the
outstretched hand Mason Scott
[Applause]
watch out
we miss this place one way good job
[Music]
kicks it in and then look at Jeremy
grant on that alley I mean I thought he
overthrew it I mean he's above the
square